e andare incontro al futuro con la
determinazione non soltanto di credere
alle nuove idee
buongiorno di fuggire
vecchie
io appunto
ho studiato qui a bologna al dams al
dams ho fatto arti visive mi perdevo
spesso a contemplare il lavoro di gli
artisti del passato che in qualche modo
avevano utilizzato la virtualità della
pittura per superare quel confine che
c'era tra tra realtà e illusione
un esempio
questo è un affresco a palazzo barberini
a roma di pietro da cortona dove
l'artista cercava in ogni modo appunto
di superare quelle che erano leggermente
diano spaziali del soffitto comunque
degli spazi che gli venivano affidati
per creare dei nuovi mondi perché l'aria
dei dei nuovi spazi e uscito dalla
biblioteca mi chiedevo come in qualche
modo io potessi utilizzare questo questo
questa idea come cosa potevo farci dato
che mi piaceva così tanto appunto e
nulla è come potevo applicarla quello
che mi circondava quindi alla agli spazi
degli edifici che amici con nella città
di bologna fondamentalmente è la
risposta a questo quesito diciamo mi è
arrivata comunque l'ho trovata nella
videoproiezione io con un computer e un
video potevo in qualche modo lavorare su
oggetti su architetture sull'esistente e
andare a modificarne le forme le le
geometrie quindi è un'idea vecchia di
500 anni che però se utilizzata con dei
nuovi linguaggi delle nuove tecnologie
può risultare vincente anzi già al
giorno d'oggi è una delle delle tendenze
diciamo che più che più vengono
utilizzati che più piacciono nulla qui
questa idea quindi è nata appunto
dicevano i 600 seicento è stato un
secolo in cui questo questo confine c'è
stato il secolo in cui il confine tra
reale non reale è caduto secolo in cui
sono nati tra il l'illusione ottica
morpho xi tutte delle forme d'arte che
in qualche modo avevano la tendenza a a
ingannare il pubblico
e quindi è il secolo
fondamentalmente in cui sono nate le c è
nata la civiltà dell'immagine è nata
anche per dire una cosa bellissima
secondo me anche poi appunto a che fare
con sé per quella città con gli edifici
la città teatro quindi il fatto di
stupire anche la la popolazione in
questo secolo sono nati anche è nata una
forma d'arte che che che ho scoperto poi
successivamente che consisteva in
decorazioni in applicazioni su chiarano
in cartapesta o in stucco quindi
materiali poveri che hanno preso il nome
di apparati effimeri appunto da cui poi
in nome della mia azienda
e queste per dire sono delle delle
tavole che sono state commissionate da
cosimo dei medici alla bottega del
bernini per per una celebrazione in
particolare erano delle applicazioni che
venivano appunto utilizzate in grandi
feste grandi grandi celebrazioni ed
erano delle scenografie di materiali
poveri che venivano applicate o
applicate agli edifici o posizionato in
piazza eccetera la particolarità di
queste di queste applicazioni era il
fatto che per la loro appunto scarsa
durevolezza e anche il costo era
abbastanza irrisorio e venivano
utilizzate come campo di sperimentazione
per tutti gli artisti che avevano
necessità appunto di di sperimentare
nuove forme d'arte nuove tendenze e per
poi se piacevano essere trasposte in
materiali più nobili quindi in marmo
eccetera un'altra particolarità di
queste di queste applicazioni era il il
fatto che per averne documentazione
venivano venivano fatti molti disegni
incisioni che poi viaggiavano in tutta
italia in tutta europa nelle botteghe
dei principali artisti e in qualche modo
segnavano quella che è scusate che
dovevo anche far partire delle altre
immagini segnavano anche quella che era
la tendenza del quelle che erano le
nuove tendenze dell'arte
proprio come se vogliamo fare un
paragone noi oggi la documentazione dei
nostri eventi la mettiamo on line su
youtube vimeo e che diventano i canali
fondamentali per sia per la
documentazione sia per lo studio dei
nostri competitor questi degli esempi
appunto di quelle immagini che vi dicevo
che mi affascinavano mi affascinavano
tantissimo e che in qualche modo sono
state il punto di partenza per tutto il
nostro lavoro e quest'idea quindi come
come l'ho sviluppata io 15 anni fa
iniziato a lavorare con con il video
intanto vi faccio vedere anche delle
immagini dei lavori poiché abbiamo
realizzato 15 anni fa iniziò per
lavorare con il video lavoravo in
nel set cinematografici e vedevo in chi
lavorava come la scarsa tendenza ad
uscire da da questo formato anche se
oggi noi stiamo anche guardando un po
però la cornice era questa cioè non si
usciva mai da questa cornice
io poi facevo lo scenografo quindi mi
occupavo fondamentalmente di prendere
oggetti e scenografie insomma di
organizzare ciò che poi andava visto
dentro questa scatola o la televisione
il cinema quello che era però c'è sempre
una cornice e questo mi ha aiutato a
capire cosa che il pubblico percepisce
ciò che io voglio che percepisca quindi
gli do un
una forma di realtà in teatro poi questa
questa forma di illusione di di prendere
in giro diciamo il pubblico è una cosa
che si è sempre utilizzata che fa parte
della nascita proprio della scenografia
del teatro e il cinema ha rubato un
sacco al teatro appunto questa tendenza
però non è mai riuscito a uscire da
quelli che sono i luoghi dedicati della
fruizione e cioè le sale
cinematografiche il teatro invece
riuscito a uscire ad andar fuori in
qualche modo ed è lì che io ho iniziato
a lavorare con con i video applicati
alla scenografia è iniziato a lavorare
con un team di creativi che all'inizio
con me lavoravano all'interno di club
un festival di musica elettronica e ce
la facciamo diciamo i vj e quello che
accomunava questi spazi era la scarsa
attenzione per quello che facevamo
perché mi fregava niente a nessuno e poi
il fatto che prevedevamo su delle
lenzuola cioè se andava bene su delle
lenzuola e ci ha lasciato quella nostra
idea invece è stata quella di prendere
il libretto ore e puntarlo direttamente
in sala su sulle superfici di questi
spazi sugli ambienti e di cercare di
lavorare sulle geometrie di questi
luoghi in modo da da da aprirli e da da
sfondargli quindi in qualche modo di
valorizzarli anche e quindi a aprirli a
nuovi mondi che erano dei mondi che
appunto fino ad allora non rimasti
inquadrati lì e non avevano mai una gran
relazione con l'ambiente che li
accoglieva e quindi non è un'idea così
nuova c'è un'idea che è nata nel
cinquecento che già quando c'è la
prospettiva fondamentalmente è nata
proprio per quello per amplificare per
ampliare il mondo reale portarlo verso
un mondo che in qualche modo avesse un
dialogo con il mondo che noi viviamo e
quindi non sono cambiate tantissime cose
anche le committenze per dire non sono
cambiate nel senso che allora erano le
grandi grandi casate erano gli sforza i
medici e cioè tra ora sono i grandi
brand
eccolo là grandi marchi che che
continuano ad aver bisogno di emozionare
di stupire il pubblico con con qualcosa
che sia avvolgente che che sia
coinvolgente e telo stupisca quindi da
deve lasciare il segno diciamo e diciamo
che per noi questa è stato abbastanza
vincente ed è fondamentale insomma per
la comunicazione che molte volte ci
sulla quale noi dobbiamo lavorare solo
per questi marchi e io qui oggi per dire
o un video alle mie spalle però un
giorno ma neanche troppo prossimo un
futuro neanche troppo prossimo potrei
avere un ologramma potrei avere delle
immagini con cui interagisco che tocco
che che possono dialogare con me col
pubblico
però sono convinto che la cosa vincente
c'è il l'idea vincente è quella di
lavorare comunque sulla realtà cioè nel
senso quello che mi piace della
videoproiezione ha proprio il fatto che
io ho una macchina e e nella macchina
c'è la macchina la posso modificare i
duemila modi posso posso entrarci dentro
posso svuotarla posso di comporla ci
posso giocare ed è un oggetto che io ho
cioè che vedo tutti i giorni quindi è
come questo questa scatola qui io potrei
trasformarla e fate parlarci in qualche
modo potrebbe parlare a me ecco questo è
stato fondamentalmente l'escursus
speciale di questa idea di come si è
sviluppata e niente io volevo farvi
vedere un video di quesi si vede un
video dei lavori dell'anno scorso
è una cosa molto bella che non esita a
fare da proprio che la pezza giardini
abbiamo scoperto
vabbè
e adesso mi dispiace perché non si vede
non si vedeva benissimo
niente per concludere se non volevo
dirvi che quello di cui vi ho parlato
tecnicamente sono si chiamava martini 3d
ed è una tecnica che possiamo dire che è
andata con noi praticamente nel 2000
agli inizi del 2000 da questa tecnica ne
sono nate tantissime altre tante altre
ne nasceranno nulla spero un giorno di
ritornare qui a parlarne